Hey.
I'm a bird.
Hey guys.
Yeah, that's right!
I'm a bird now!
Funniest shit ever, guys!
They turned me into a fucking bird!
Don't worry guys.
I also have... I have arms.
I don't know if... Am I okay?
Is that the truth?
Don't... Yeah, that's me!
I'm a bird now!
Did you guys... Could you guys tell from the thumbnail?
That I was gonna be a bird?
Yeah, that's right.
Full body tracking.
Is the sound okay?
I've evolved.
Bro, okay.
Have you ever seen a bird shake its... tail?
Yeah!
I can also do this.
I can extend... extend my neck a little bit.
The sound is okay.
Oh, that's great.
That's good to know.
That's all I need to know.
Anyway.
Yeah!
Hey guys!
This is not the announcement, by the way.
Don't... Don't worry.
This is... This is not the announcement, guys.
I need to fix my head... I need to fix my... my... myself a bit more.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I think that's better.
Alright.
So anyway.
This is not the announcement.
If you guys wanna know what the announcement is, you gotta wait until the very end.
But for now, we gotta enjoy some... some Doki Birds.
Whoa...
That's stupid.
Okay.
So like... I actually have like... I can do different things with it.
So like... hey... I can be... I can be a little happy.
And then... Whoa...
Oh my god!
I'm sad!
And then I can be...
I can be...
I can just be sad.
I bet this is sad.
But I can be sad.
And then I can be like...
Whoa.
Huh?
And then I can change my eye color.
So it's...
Oh wait!
That's the mirror?
Oh my god!
Wait!
That's a mir... Sorry, I didn't know what mirrors are.
After becoming a bird.
I didn't realize that...
That's a mirror?
Oh my god!
That was the fucking mirror!
Where's the camera?
Where...
Wait a minute.
Where's the camera then?
If that's the mir... Okay sorry.
Now I'm facing the camera.
Where the fuck is the camera?
Where...
Sorry.
I didn't realize...
That was the...
That was the mirror.
So... Yeah!
Yeah.
So I have hands actually.
Okay so this was done by...
I'm so sorry I forgot the name.
The creator.
I saw them post like...
A crow model.
And I was like... Oh my god.
I want one.
That's so funny.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Doki bird is real!
Oh my god!
She's real!
So...
I had to...
I don't know where the camera went guys.
Where did the camera go?
I needed it to face me!
Guys!
I can't find the camera!
Oh no!
I haven't been in VR chat in so long.
I don't...
I don't know where...
I don't know where the camera is!
Wait okay.
What if I...
Okay.
If I do a smooth... No it can't be that.
Where did it go?
Where...
Where did the camera go?
Guys!
I actually don't know where it went!
Where did it go?
Why is there two Doki...
The thing behind me!
It's a mirror!
Where's the camera?
Oh I found it!
I found the camera!
Okay guys.
Alright.
Now it should face me.
Oh!
Sorry.
That's my head.
Oh!
That's not good.
Oh okay.
Sorry guys.
This crow lost it's...
This crow doesn't...
Doesn't really have hands.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay.
Auto level.
There we go!
Look!
Now I'm in the grass!
Okay let me pull it back up a little bit.
Look guys!
Oh my god!
My leg!
Oh my leg!
What's going on with my leg?
What?
Guys give me a sec.
Guys this...
The crow is not doing so well.
Okay there we go.
There we go.
Now... Okay.
Now it feels a lot better.
Okay!
Okay.
So...
Sounds good right?
The sound is...
The sound is okay right guys?
Is it?
Sound guy.
I'm sorry but like...
I... Okay you said sound is okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Sound is okay.
Okay that's good.
Anyway.
Guys before we go on our little...
Before we go on our little adventure.
I just say I have a gift for you.
But like...
So like the gift is like unrelated to...
I'm sorry.
I can't...
I look so fucking stupid.
Okay.
Anyway.
So like...
So...
The...
The gift...
The gift is unrelated to...
Oh my god but look at me.
Why?
Look at me walk.
Look at how I walk.
Wee!
Look.
Okay look.
It's like...
I really enjoy the simple things in life.
Because like look at this.
Whoa.
Huh?
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay.
Anyway.
Anyway as I was saying.
As I was saying.
So like...
So...
So there's actually...
There's actually more.
There's actually more to this.
So like the thing is.
I did say there's gonna be a gift.
Right?
So like the gift is unrelated to the announcement.
So let me... Let me grab...
Well there's like several...
There's like more than one gift.
So let me...
Let me...
Let me... Oh wait no but I can do like...
I think you do different expressions.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So... Yeah.
I forgot.
I forgot I could do different expressions.
With like my hands.
Um.
But like...
Yeah.
So...
So basically...
Um.
There's several gifts.
So I should get the... I should get the first gift for you guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Let me... Let me...
Grab it real fast.
Uh.
It's the gift...
You migrating.
As in how's with you migrating for the self.
Okay.
It's summer.
It's already...
It's not winter anymore.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Anyway.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Alright.
So there's actually...
There's actually...
Several gifts.
Okay?
Hey.
Okay.
I'm not...
I'm not... The crow was the...
The red hair.
But yes.
I do have an actual 3D GV.
I do.
Bring the crow.
What do you mean?
What do you mean bring the crow back?
Look at me.
Also I have full body tracking right now.
So.
Yeah.
It's like...
Now...
Oh.
I don't remember my dance.
I don't...
What do you mean?
Okay.
So.
What does this mean?
Alright.
Let me... Where did I put this?
Where did I... Okay.
So there's supposed to be like an image that shows up.
So.
The first...
Oh.
What's that sound?
That's my Logitech G Pro Wireless.
Oh.
Okay.
Shit.
Where is it?
Okay.
We'll put it here.
I'm sorry.
I'm professional.
Okay.
Now where am I?
Oh.
No.
That's different.
Look!
Yes!
It's not in storage yet.
But like...
It's like...
Whoa!
Be prepared!
Be prepared guys.
So.
Yes!
This is made by Preachy.
Rigging done by Entity.
You might recognize those names.
I was so happy that Preachy wanted to work with me on the Chibi 3D model.
I always loved her models.
And...
The thing is.
I wanted to work with her because I wanted her to make plushies!
I wanted to have like Chibi plushies!
Based off of like, you know, my Chibi 3D models!
So...
That was like the main reason...
That was like the main reason uh... why I wanted to work with her.
So like... Yes!
Yes!
It's not gonna be up in storage for a bit because like I wanna make sure it looks okay before I...
I don't want you guys to like pre-order and then like wait a year because we were going through like pre-production.
So like it's more so like, you know, a sneak peek of like uh... of it going to... You want the crow?
What about this?
Where are you guys?
What do you mean you want the crow plushie?
What do you mean?
I...
Look at me!
I can raise my legs!
I can kick!
What do you mean?
The crow... Okay, the crow could kick.
The crow could barely extend its arms.
Look!
I can like T-pose and everything.
What do you mean?
What do you mean you missed the bird?
I am the bird!
It's literally a donkey bird!
Okay!
In the future we'll have... You literally met the crow for like... for like 10 minutes!
How do you already fall in love with the bird?
How do you...
What is this fucking Princess and the Frog shit?
How do you fall in love with the bird already?
It's been 10 minutes.
Anyway... Anyway...
Um...
But yes, this was like the main reason why I really, really, really wanted to work with Poochie for this model.
I really wanted to have plushies!
And I felt like her style was... worked so well in plushie form.
So I was like super excited.
I was like, yes!
Yes!
So... So I'm really happy to be able to work with her and like being able to... You know... I mean look at it.
It's so cool!
It's so cute!
Yeah.
Anyway, it took a while to find a world for this.
So...
I didn't know what world to go to!
I just literally was like...
I was looking at Animal Crossing worlds and then... Because we don't have any actual personal 3D world because that's a lot of work.
And I already have like a million other projects ongoing right now.
So like...
A 3D world is sort of like...
You know... Not in the near future... Not in the next coming months guys.
So I had to like borrow some worlds while I was exploring VRChat.
And I was like... Oh my god!
Like I even went to like...
I even looked at like Pokemon Mystery Dungeon worlds and everything.
And then...
The perfect one was literally Minecraft.
Because I needed an open field.
I needed...
I needed a...
I needed like an open field.
And I was like...
Okay... This is... This is an open field.
It's Minecraft.
It's...
It's Minecraft!
It's an open field!
Uh...
But yeah... So that is...
A gift... Wait... Where's my arm?
This is...
Where's my arm?
Is this my arm?
Oh!
Okay...
This is gift number one!
Gift number two!
Gift number two...
Is...
Basically...
You see this?
This is gonna be for free.
For all you guys.
You can do anything you want with the 3D model.
So...
Um... It will be uploaded later on Sketchfab.
Um... And you will be able to download it and do whatever the fuck you want.
But like... Like you know...
Not really everything.
You want...
I won't be putting the crow though.
The crow is exclusively for me.
So...
Um...
No crows though.
No crows.
But the...
This will be for you guys.
You can do what you want.
Make animation.
Put me in a game that you're making.
Uh...
Mod me into something.
Anything you want to do.
Um... As long as you don't monetize it.
That's all.
That's all I ask for.
As long as you don't make money off of it.
I mean if you were making a video and you're using this.
That's fine.
But as long as you don't make like physical products and like mass produce them.
And make money out of it.
Then no.
Cause I'm gonna do that.
.
You can't do it.
Cause I'm gonna do that.
So you're not allowed to.
.
No!
No crow!
Because the crow.
I didn't ask permission if I could.
Cause like I...
I don't know.
I didn't ask permission if I could put it up for public.
Cause it's like...
It's their crow model.
And I asked them if they could reskin it to me.
And oh my god.
You guys really want...
Okay fine.
I'll be the fucking crow.
.
Alright.
Where am I?
There you go.
Are you happy?
Are you... Look.
I'll advertise my plushie as a crow.
So yes!
Um...
.
I'll give... I'll give the dragoons...
What they want.
So...
Yes.
Um...
This will be put for pre-orders.
Maybe in... in a month.
Or...
Or two.
I don't know.
I'm still...
We're going through pre-production right now.
And it's so hard.
For the plushies.
Cause it's like... They send you...
For anyone that's ever made a plushie before.
The first draft...
Looks fucking ridiculous.
And it looks like really bad.
And you have to go through multiple drafts.
Before it looks good.
So like...
I want to be sure that we have an actual good looking plushie.
Before I put it up for pre-order.
So yes.
You gotta wait a month or maybe two.
I'm not sure.
But I just wanted to show you guys.
Maybe a month.
Maybe a month later.
You might notice the store is...
The store is...
Offline right now.
Cause...
When it's back online.
It's gonna look so cool.
Like it took us a long time.
To like...
Get that store ready.
For you guys.
But there's gonna be like...
New stuff on it.
And...
It's gonna look... Or maybe not.
Actually no.
I remember one of my staff members were like...
Yeah there's not gonna be... The new products aren't gonna be on it yet.
But yes!
Lots of stuff was being shipped out.
Apparently.
My distributor told me that...
Like...
They shipped out like...
2000 plus products already.
In like... Within a week.
So that was fucking crazy.
I was like holy shit.
I can... I can actually like...
Umm...
I can actually like work on new stuff now.
Like this.
And someone's like...
Wait dookie's not a tomato?
She's a fucking burp.
Hahahaha This is just another...
This is just another skin suit.
So you can imagine like...
A tomato like piloting.
Like you know in Gundam?
Where you're in a mecha suit.
Just...
Every time... Every time like...
My true form...
Is in a different body.
There's like a tomato piloting it.
So...
Hahahaha So there's a...
There's a tomato inside me too.
Don't worry guys.
There's a tomato inside me.
Inside all of us.
So do not worry.
Okay let me... let me go back.
Let me go back.
Hahahaha
Anyway...
Uh...
well where am I?
Okay so like... I'm really excited because I can't wait to make...
Uh... merch.
Based off of... uh...
Based off of my chibi form.
So like... I mean like...
Whoa... I love working with her.
Her style is so...
Her style is so cute.
Um... we went through like...
So many drafts.
Uh... because...
Oh my gosh.
I'll show you guys the sketches of that in another stream.
Um... but like...
I went through like so many...
Uh... drafts when it came to like...
What it was gonna look like in terms of like...
The shape of everything.
Cause I'm like such a perfectionist in everything.
So... I'll show you guys in the next...
What's my next stream?
I'll show you guys on Monday... cause I don't stream on Sunday.
I'll show you guys on Monday.
Hahahaha Hahahaha I'm gonna make you guys watch Sandland.
Hahahaha Hahahaha I'll be streaming Sandland on Monday and I'm gonna make you guys watch it.
If you guys wanna see the behind the scenes.
You have to watch Sandland.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Oh yes.
Anyway...
I need to put this away now.
I need to get on the rest of the screen.
Hahahaha Anyway...
So... I do have...
I don't have any props.
Well I do have one prop.
But like I said there's still the announcement.
Umm...
I have this.
Wait...
Wait a minute... Where is it?
Hahahaha Hahahaha I thought I had this.
Wait give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I need a...
Sorry I'm gonna go big for a sec guys.
Okay I'm gonna become big.
Alright watch this.
Oh my god where am I?
Oh my god.
Why is it... I can't see.
Okay okay there we go.
Alright so I'm big now.
Anyway...
I have this.
Hahahaha As I was saying.
We do have the announcement.
Oh my gosh where's my arm?
Okay this is... The announcement is in this gift box chat.
The announcement is in this gift box.
Oh my gosh how do I...
How do I open the lid?
Hahahaha Hahahaha Give me a sec.
Where's my hand?
Hahahaha Okay.
Okay.
Okay give me a sec.
Oh my god.
Can I open it?
Guys we will...
You will have your announcement when I figure out how to open this box.
Okay.
My hand is...
here.
Alright.
Please.
Hahaha.
Oh my god for the love of god.
I will learn how to open a box.
Hahahaha.
Guys.
Guys I swear to god.
Okay.
Okay give me a sec.
Alright.
We'll learn...
figure this out.
Okay guys.
Today's stream we're gonna figure out how to open a box.
Okay.
Hahahaha.
Where's my hand going to?
Ahhhhhh.
Ah Anthony.
I don't see anything.
I just see inside my head.
Hahahaha.
Anthony we have a problem.
I thought I tested everything but I didn't test the big model.
Hahahaha.
All I see.
I see the inside of my head so I have to look at the camera to figure it out.
I have to.
I have to look at the camera to figure out how to open the box.
Where's my hand?
Alright.
This is the present hand.
This is my hand.
This entire stream will be me figuring.
We won't get the announcement until I figure this out.
Hahahaha.
Guys.
We will.
Wooo.
Okay.
Anyway.
This is going to be a test.
I'm not giving you the announcement yet.
I'm going to test this out.
Where are you?
Okay.
Oh no.
I put the lid back on.
No.
Hahahaha.
Nooooo.
I put the lid back on.
Okay.
Um.
Guys.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
We're going to figure.
We're going to figure this out.
Guys.
Where's my hand?
Okay.
Alright.
Come on lid.
Get off.
Lid.
Okay guys.
We'll deal with that later.
Hahahaha.
Future.
Future Doki.
We'll figure.
We'll figure that out.
Hahahaha.
Future Doki.
We'll figure that out.
Another time.
Because.
Because I don't know how to do it.
I don't.
I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
Entity are you watching?
Entity.
Entity please.
I'm sorry I lied.
I was like.
Entity I know you said.
You were like.
Oh yeah.
Just make sure.
Let me know.
If everything is okay.
And like.
I was like.
Just finished testing it.
Um.
I think everything is good.
I lied.
Hahahaha.
I was trying to find worlds to go to.
I'm sorry.
I lied.
I thought it was fixed.
I didn't think you.
I didn't think.
Hahahaha.
I didn't think that like.
I can open the box.
It's a box.
What do you mean?
I can't open the box.
I'm sorry.
I'm freaking out.
I'm sorry Entity.
Please.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I won't lie again.
She says that she naturally lied.
But for real this time.
I won't lie again.
Hahahaha.
So anyway.
I guess we could explore.
Um.
I guess honestly.
Like this entire stream was just me.
Wanting to show you guys.
This.
Oh my gosh.
I look like the super.
Saiyan pose.
What was it?
You know.
Like.
When all of them are.
All the bad guys.
The bad guys.
They're like the super saiyan squad.
Or like the saiyan squad.
And they're like.
Hoooo.
Hahahaha.
Yes.
The Jinyu.
The Jinyu force.
I'm so sorry.
A lot of Dragon Ball Z fans are going to send me hate mail now.
Hahahaha.
Yeah.
Like that.
Hahahaha.
Let's go get a green screen.
You guys deserve a green screen world.
Um.
Let's see.
Search world.
Green.
Green screen.
Wait.
Maybe I can just search up green.
I'm a professional.
Green.
Okay.
Selfie and green screen.
I joined like a.
A public Minecraft world.
For like VR.
On accident before the stream started.
And there were like children.
And I was like.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Kids can have VR headsets now?
Like what the fuck.
Hahahaha.
Oh my god.
What's worse than iPad kids?
Oh.
VR kids.
VR children.
That's worse than.
That's worse than iPad kids.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Where's my camera?
Where is it?
Oh.
World.
Where is it?
Guys.
I always struggle trying to find my.
Oh.
Is that the camera?
There it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah!
Wait.
That's not a green screen.
What the fuck is that?
Hahahaha.
Where is the.
Wait.
Where did my camera go?
That's not a green screen.
There's like a square.
A grey square.
Where's my camera?
Camera?
Sorry.
I'm always struggling trying to find my camera.
Camera?
Where are you?
Oh.
There you are.
Okay.
Now.
Yes!
Okay.
Professional.
I am a professional.
Alright.
Let's.
Auto level.
Look at me.
Yes.
Alright.
So.
So now.
Now.
I have the green screen.
So I can be like.
And then be like.
Ba da da da da da da da.
Bump bump.
Ow.
I don't remember the newer one.
I haven't seen the newer one enough.
Like I know like.
Guys I've only been streaming for like 3 to 4 months guys.
I don't remember.
Hahahaha.
Guys.
My memory is not as good as it used to be.
Hahaha.
I got brain rot.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
But.
Uh.
Ba da da.
Bump.
Hahahaha.
And then.
Ba da da.
Bump.
And then I would have like the trophy tomato there.
And then one time I would be like.
Yay.
You know.
For the dragoon.
I would be like.
Yay.
And then.
And then I don't remember.
Hahahaha.
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
You know I used to.
I could have got a masters degree.
Hahahaha.
You know.
I used to be a straight A student.
What happened to me.
Hahaha.
Okay.
So.
Um.
Oh yeah.
I forgot.
There's like different expressions.
Different expressions.
So I can.
You know.
I can smile.
Be like.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I saw that short about like.
The avatar for keeping up with Kardashians.
And then.
Toph was like.
Yeah.
Hahahaha.
So it's sort of like.
In my head.
Stuck in my head for a little bit now.
And then.
Yeah.
I have the.
Sparkle eye.
Yeah.
Hahahaha.
Oh wait.
Ah.
Hahahaha.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh shit.
I'm cringing.
I'm like.
Cringing.
Alright.
I'm gonna be.
I'm gonna be smug.
Heh.
Okay.
And then.
I can be the other smug.
I'll be like.
Heh.
And then.
And then there's.
This one.
Wait.
Where's my hand?
There it is.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
Ah.
Hahahaha.
Because I want to open my.
Ah.
Okay.
And then.
Oh.
Oh wait.
No.
That's sad.
Because I'm crying.
You can see here.
I'm actually crying.
Sorry.
Wrong way.
This one is the.
Hahahaha.
Anyway.
Ah.
What else?
Oh yeah.
Let me.
Oh it's looking at me.
No.
Don't look at me.
And.
Ah.
Fucking Oshii is here.
Wait.
Am I here?
Where am I?
Why am I not moving?
Hahahaha.
Where's my camera?
No.
The world is all green.
So I don't know where I am.
Hahahaha.
The world is all green.
Where am I?
Guys give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out where I am.
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
Look.
Oh.
There I am.
Hahahaha.
Guys.
I figured out where I am.
Hahahaha.
Guys look at me.
I'm prancing.
Yeah.
Hahahaha.
I couldn't figure out where I was.
Oh my god.
The entire world was just green.
It was so scary.
I couldn't tell.
Oh wait.
But you need the green screen.
Fuck.
Okay.
Uhhhh.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I need to prance to a green.
Okay.
There we go.
Hahahaha.
Guys I'm figuring it out.
Okay.
Now I can prance.
Look at that.
Yay.
Wooo.
Wait.
Where am I?
Oh there I am.
Okay.
I always need to figure out where I am.
Hahahaha.
There we go.
Alright.
So.
I can.
Okay.
Let me.
I can be like.
Whoa.
And I can.
Move my neck like that.
And be like.
Hey guys.
Hahahaha.
Yeah that's right.
That's right.
This is your Oshi.
Right here.
Hahahaha.
But yes.
I can.
I can change my eye color.
But I like the black eyes better.
I feel like it fits in.
I can like remove the pins.
And I can be like.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then I can do like.
And then sparkle.
And happy.
And then I have.
And I have some like.
Cursed ass wings.
I guess.
Like.
Like I can fly.
Hahahaha.
I can be like.
Yay.
Hahahaha.
Kaka.
I can be like.
I'm sorry.
I think I have the most fun with this one.
The most.
For sure.
Hahahaha.
I can be like.
Wait.
Can I do the intro dance as.
As the bird?
Okay.
I mean it looks wonky.
I feel like.
Maybe like this?
Ba da da da.
Ba.
Wait.
Where am I?
I'm sorry.
I feel like I'm an old person.
Where am I?
I'm lost in the supermarket.
Ba da da da.
Bum.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
I want my arms extended now.
I'm gonna sit down.
What does it look like when I sit down?
Let's see.
Where's my camera?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
All I'm saying is if you see a fucking bird.
That's sitting like this.
The bird has issues.
Like it's actually not good.
A bird should not be sitting down.
Hahahaha.
If you see a wild bird that's sitting like this.
Please call a veterinarian.
Or I don't know.
Do something.
A bird should not be sitting down.
It's not natural.
But.
Oh my god.
I look amazing as a bird.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
I look so fucking stupid.
But like.
Hahahaha.
I'm just a bird.
Okay.
Let me.
Uh.
Go back to.
Oh hey.
Oh I look.
Look.
See guys.
Guys.
Look.
I look fantastic.
I know.
Oh my god.
The tracking is so good.
Hahahaha.
The tracking is actually.
So good.
Hahahaha.
I love just like.
Being able to just sit down like this.
Guys.
Um.
No.
You guys don't want the bird back.
Stop lying.
Stop lying to yourselves.
Guys.
I know you guys don't actually want the bird back.
Okay.
I know.
I know that you don't actually want the bird back.
Um.
But yes.
I have full body tracking right now.
Um.
I'm sitting down because I want to know what it looks like when I'm sitting down.
And I guess like.
Hahahaha.
Wow.
My people need me.
Guys.
I can touch my toes.
Look.
It's not my fault.
My arms are short.
My.
Hahahaha.
It's not.
It's not my fault.
My arms are short.
Hahahaha.
My people need me.
Goodbye now.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
Um.
Anyway.
Uh.
I think that's.
That's really it.
I just really wanted to do.
Uh.
I just really wanted to do this stream.
For the sake of showing you guys this.
I know I said like.
Let's visit some worlds.
You know what.
No.
Let's visit one world.
We'll visit one world guys.
Before I.
Wait.
Okay.
Was Entity in chat?
Sorry Entity.
I don't know what you said.
Guys.
Parry what Entity said to us.
In chat.
What did Entity say?
What's the announcement?
No.
That's what I'm saying.
I'll do like.
Maybe I'll go visit one world.
And then.
Uh.
Um.
And then.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
Do I have to restart?
Entity.
Hahahaha.
Do I.
Do I have to.
Oh wait.
I can take.
I forgot.
Guys.
There was one thing.
I can be bald.
Oh my god.
I look so wrong.
I look so fucking wrong.
Hahahaha.
Yes.
I can take off my hat.
But I don't.
I don't like that.
I look like some fucking generic anime girl now.
With all my hat.
Chat.
To be fair.
I actually look.
I look like.
I look so generic with all my hat.
The hat is what makes me special.
Um.
Anyway.
Okay.
Let's get back up.
I just want to know what.
It looks like when I.
Ugh.
When I sit down.
Um.
But yes.
Let's see.
Let us.
See if it's fixed now.
Do I have to restart?
I don't know.
We'll find out.
I don't have to restart.
Okay.
Okay guys.
I'm gonna.
Wait.
Oh god.
Okay.
Look at me.
Auto level.
Okay.
Nice.
And then auto level.
But where am I?
Where?
Oh no.
I'm too big now.
Okay.
Auto level.
There we go.
And then I'll be here.
Okay guys.
We're gonna do a demonstration.
Of the announcement.
Slash gift.
We're gonna practice a little bit.
Okay.
Here it is.
Here.
I can see it now.
But.
Ugh.
Okay.
Guys give me a sec.
We're gonna.
We're gonna figure this out.
Okay.
Please.
Why is this so difficult?
Entity I'm sorry.
This is what I mean when I said I'm so bad at gestures.
Okay.
We're gonna figure this out.
Guys.
Okay.
We're gonna figure this out.
Guys.
We're gonna.
Okay.
The first step.
The moment I figure this out.
We can go to the world and I can give you your announcement.
Okay.
Firmly grasp it.
I'm firmly grasping it.
I'm.
Okay.
Alright.
This is.
He said rock and roll.
Oh.
I did it.
Wait.
Where's the camera?
Camera is.
Okay.
Camera is somewhere here.
Because that's where I'm looking at.
Where did the camera go?
Where.
Where are you?
You're.
You're here somewhere.
You're here.
You're in front of me.
Oh.
There you are.
Okay.
Alright.
That's what we're trying to do.
Okay.
And then.
Wait.
This is the wrong arm.
I'm going to go for this.
Oh my god.
What's this POV?
Doki eats you.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I'm practicing.
I'm practicing right now.
Okay.
Guys.
I figured it out.
I figured it out this time.
I did it.
Are you proud of me?
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Let's go to.
Let's go to a.
Oh.
This would be the perfect place.
I want to go here.
No.
This is a random world.
This is a public world.
No.
No children please.
No children.
That's all I ask.
Oh god.
Okay.
Worlds.
I've been getting a lot of messages.
I think on Discord.
But like.
I don't know.
Oh no.
Where am I?
Okay.
New instance.
Invite.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank god.
I was freaking out there.
I thought I was going to get children again.
So.
Good thing.
Good thing it's not kids.
Uh.
Not children.
Okay.
Let's go back to.
Small.
Um.
Where's my camera?
This is like my entire world.
Just.
Where's my camera?
Dude.
Where's my car?
Alright.
Camera?
Oh there you are.
Guys.
I think this is a good spot.
To.
You know.
To like.
Have.
Look!
Isn't this a great spot?
To see your gift?
It's like.
It's the Pokemon Mystery Dungeon world.
Where you like.
Almost died.
And get reincarnated as a Pokemon.
Look!
Isn't it so cute?
I love.
I love Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
It's one of my.
Uh.
Favorite.
It's literally one of my favorite Pokemon series.
Despite all the shit I say about Pokemon.
Um.
New version.
New version Pokemon.
Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
On the DS.
That shit was fire.
Uh.
That was peak.
Peak Pokemon for me.
And.
That and Crystal.
Pokemon Crystal.
And Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
Peak.
Um.
Peak Pokemon for me.
We don't talk about the newer Pokemon games.
I'm sorry if you guys actually like the newer Pokemon games.
But.
Um.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright guys.
So.
Um.
I know I said.
Like.
We're visiting VR Chat Worlds.
Yay!
But that was sort of like a clickbait type thing.
Well I mean.
We visited this world.
We visited three worlds.
Technically.
So like.
I did my thing.
I.
I didn't clickbait.
Because I did say.
We're visiting VR Chat Worlds.
And that was three worlds.
And mostly.
I just wanted to like.
Show you guys this.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And then that's me teabagging you.
Um.
Oh that should have been a green screen.
Fuck.
God damn it.
That should have been a fucking green screen.
Alright.
Um.
Video editors.
You can crop out all that background.
You know.
And then.
I wanted to showcase this for you guys.
Because.
I mean.
I mean come on.
I look fucking cute.
And also.
Your new favorite.
Oshii.
Crowbird.
Like.
I don't know.
Crowbird?
Doki Crow?
Crowdokia?
I don't know.
I don't know what sounds good.
Um.
I mean you could just literally be like.
Doki bird.
Because it's literally a bird.
Oh my gosh.
My legs.
My fucking legs.
Um.
What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's gift time.
Oh.
It's on B.
Sorry.
I was like.
Where is it?
Where's the gift?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna eat the sun!
You can't come out of the ocean.
Like Godzilla.
Okay.
Um.
Where is.
Alright.
It's gift time.
Wait.
The camera's so tiny now.
No.
The camera's not here.
VRChat please.
Can you make the camera more noticeable?
I don't ask for much.
I just wanna know where the fuck the camera is.
VRChat.
This is all I ask.
Where's the camera?
Okay.
You're.
You're here.
Which means.
You're below me.
Which means you're somewhere here.
But like where?
I'm not blind!
It's literally so hard to see!
It's different!
Okay.
Uh.
Don't look at me.
Okay.
And then.
Maybe I can find it here.
Where are you?
Please.
This is literally all we need.
I can't end it until I find the camera.
Where could you be?
You should be blue!
No!
This is not it!
That's not the camera!
Okay.
It's like a blue dot.
But like.
You're clearly here somewhere.
But like where?
Oh.
There you are!
You're so fucking tiny!
Holy shit!
You're like literally a dot!
Okay.
No no no no no.
If you see what I see.
You're literally just a dot for me.
Okay.
There it is.
Oh my god.
How the fuck was I supposed to see that?
Like.
Okay.
Alright.
For real now.
For real.
Okay.
Box.
Alright guys.
I have.
It's announcement time.
You've all waited for this.
Everybody.
It's finally.
It's finally announcement time.
Guys.
As soon as I open this box.
We're gonna get our announcement.
Give me a sec.
As soon as we open this box.
Okay.
The moment I open this box.
Come on.
Please.
For the love of god.
Please open.
That's all I ask you.
That's all I ask.
Why is it so.
Oh.
I see the lid open.
Do you guys see that?
The lid is opening.
But I never could get it right.
And I don't know why.
No.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Where did the camera go?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Camera is somewhere here.
Camera is like.
Okay.
Guys.
No.
It's not empty.
I swear to god.
It will show up the moment I find the camera.
Where are you?
It's not empty.
It's stuck to the box at the end.
It's like.
There's like a hidden compartment.
It's a hidden compartment.
I just need to find you guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Now let me move a little bit closer.
Okay.
Fuck.
Sorry.
Take two.
Okay.
Don't worry guys.
I have a secret gift for you.
Give me a sec.
Guys.
I'm a professional.
Give me a sec.
It's gonna work.
Alright.
Three.
Two.
One.
Oh my god.
Three.
Two.
One.
Three.
Two.
One.
Guys!
Wait.
Why am I not.
Actually I'm muting myself.
Yeah!
That's right!
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I'm a mess right now.
That's right!
New skin suit.
This is done.
It will be.
June 22nd.
Next week.
At 5pm.
PST.
So what does that mean about the old skin suit?
I mean you literally just revealed.
Um.
You just literally just revealed.
Your like chibi 3D model.
And like you know your chibi.
Okay not chibi.
Your crowbird model.
And also like the plushie and everything.
Are you just not gonna care about.
That old skin suit.
No!
This skin suit.
Is still a part of me.
It just means.
It's like a new outfit.
You know.
But like instead of.
Like regular normies.
Like normie vtubers.
Where they like you know change clothes.
I can change.
Skin suits.
But the new skin suit.
Is gonna be the main primary.
Skin suit.
This would be like retro doki.
Okay this is gonna be like retro doki.
We might not see retro doki.
Anymore or not.
Like maybe like 1% in the future.
But like.
She's still a part of me.
And like I'm still gonna be selling merch.
Of retro doki.
And like have retro doki.
And make like cameos and stuff.
So yes because the true form.
Is the tomato inside of us all along.
Here?
I think.
The tomato is right here.
It's not in my stomach.
It's like in my head.
Okay?
Because the true form.
Is inside of me.
In here.
In the head.
Right here.
So yes.
Retro doki might not make much of an appearance.
After the 22nd.
Any future merch.
Unless we're doing like.
Retro stuff.
Like you know the.
Altagirl doki.
And all that stuff.
And like have like.
Stands of that.
And stuff like that.
Like chibi stuff.
For all my past iterations.
As doki.
And all my outfits as doki.
We're still gonna do that stuff.
But moving forward.
For like sponsors.
Brand deals.
Future streams.
Future identity.
Will be new skin suit.
So look forward to the new.
I was so nervous.
About my new skin suit.
Because I don't know.
It's different.
You saw the silhouette.
It is different.
So I hope you guys.
It's like a combination.
Of past, present and future.
So like I grew up.
I feel like I grew a lot.
As a content creator.
Over the years.
I might not feel like I'm.
Like this.
As much as I used to in the past.
You know.
It is a pretty old skin suit.
So like.
It was time for an upgrade.
Design wise.
And like personality.
Like how I feel on the outside.
To match more.
Of how I feel on the inside.
So that's why.
I do hope you guys like it.
We went through so many.
Me and my new mama.
Went through so many drafts.
And then I got my old mama.
To help me as well.
To figure out what exactly I wanted.
And uh.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Yeehaw.
All I'm saying.
Is that you might be like.
Wow Dokie.
I'm putting in a new Fallout show.
With the ghoul.
No!
It was not because of the ghoul.
I had that idea.
Before the ghoul was a thing.
So I need to tell you guys right now.
I did not got inspired by the ghoul.
I had the idea.
My mama.
Had the idea.
Of okay.
So the idea is like uh.
Bounty Hunter.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
That's so good.
That's such a good idea!
And then I saw it!
And then like a month later, the fucking ghoul popped up!
And I was like, what the fu-
So, I'll tell you guys right now.
I mean it's obvious, like the trailer was like a Bounty Hunter theme, but like yes, the theme is Bounty Hunter!
So, that is all I'm gonna give you guys in terms of like hints and stuff.
You'll find out next week on what it is.
Anyway guys, that's really all I wanted to do for the stream.
It was a short stream, but next week is gonna be a lot.
Next week, we have also have a collab with Mint next week!
We're gonna be playing a spooky game!
So we have that, and then we have Sandland!
I'm gonna talk about everything on the Sandland stream, so you better come!
I- cause I know you guys are gonna like it.
I know none of you guys actually watch the Sandland stream, so...
If you wanna know behind the scenes, and maybe more hints about my new skin suit, you better come to the Sandland stream on Monday!
Cause I know not a lot of people wanna watch Sandland, but I'm gonna make you guys watch Sandland!
I know, I know Sandland is not like very popular, but you guys have- you wanna know about behind the scenes for everything!
You gotta come!
Hey guys!
As always everybody, stay- wait, where's the camera?
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around!
To get that blood flowing!
And if you suffer me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Okay guys, I need to shimmy over to the OBS.
The transition isn't as seamless as I thought it's gonna be!
Bye!